heads up guys my name is a channel and
welcome to 2016 hope you guys had a
happy new year and I hope you enjoyed
this new intro that I'm gonna be
sticking in all my videos because this
year we're gonna get pretty serious when
I hopefully make up some some more
videos and and get this channel growing
even even more so first of all this
video is going to be the 2016 update
video in which I talk about what is
actually going to happen this year and
my plan for kind of the year right so
that you guys know what kind of content
to expect and also if you have any
questions or concerns and one are you
can just drop it in the comments below
and i'll reply to them just so that you
guys know what's happening and and maybe
you maybe you can even give me some
ideas as to what you want to see but
basically this is going to be the plan
okay first of all Sparkie see Sparkie
engine that is going to be the primary
focus of this year I'm going to develop
that engine as much as I can I'm gonna
be spending way more time working on
that end in this year than I did last
year and by the end of the year it
should be a pretty capable 3d engine
okay I'm gonna say probably is gonna
have some kind of like level editor by
then and it's gonna just yeah it's going
to be pretty pretty good hopefully right
so I'm gonna I'm not going to make too
many comments on what exactly is coming
next for Sparky because you'll see that
in later videos but um but the idea is
that it's this year's going to be
focused a lot on Sparky okay so with
that in mind though what I'm actually
going to do is I'm actually going to be
putting out weekly Sparky dev vlogs okay
so every single week on Monday evening
australian eastern daylight time zone as
the sand of time whatever basically my
time right i'm gonna be putting out
every single Monday evening unless I go
away or something in which case I will
let you guys know every single Monday
evening i will be putting out a video
which covers exactly what I did over the
past week for Sparky I'll show off any
new kind of technology or new things or
maybe new ways that you can use it and
also update you guys as to what's going
to happen in the next week so basically
what i plan to do this week before next
dev vlog okay so it's going to be a very
organized kind of straw
should project I'm I'm quiet from pretty
serious about this so this is going to
be it's going to work out really well
and i'll keep you guys up to date with
these weekly dev logs okay probably also
going to as the engine kind of starts
getting you know better and better and
actually becomes useful / we start
putting out videos and tutorials how to
actually use barky to make games and
basically how I kind of intend things to
be written in Sparky okay and all that
stuff so that'll come as well because a
lot of people were asking me if I could
make videos on how to make games with
Sparky but the issue is that it's not up
to like the API changes so frequently
right now because it's very early in
development there really isn't much of a
point in in my opinion putting out
videos like that because um because they
will be irrelevant like in the next few
months or something but once the engine
kind of stabilizes and once I'm happy
with it I will stop what I will start
putting out videos like that but there
will be weekly dev logs okay that's a
promise from me it will absolutely
happen also since mark use a game engine
and in my opinion one of the best ways
to make sure that your cam engine is
working and actually test it out and
make sure it's user-friendly and all
that stuff and just basically ensure
that it's a quality game engine is to
actually you know make a game with it
right so I'm also going to be one again
once the engine gets up to the point
where it can support a game I will be a
kind of starting some kind of game
project okay it'll be a 3d game it might
be like a first-person shooter or
something like that not one hundred
percent sure you because I haven't
decided but basically i will be starting
quite a large game project which will be
using Sparky right and the primary
purpose for that of course is to make a
game because you know why not that's fun
but also to make sure that the engine is
actually you know a viable game engine
to use right for games so once I start
making that game whatever it may be I
will also be doing kind of dead logs and
weekly updates and whatnot about that
and showing off that all the new
technology and all that kind of stuff so
that should be a lot of fun as well I'm
really excited to actually do something
like that I'll also try to live stream
these two things so both development
he and development on this game whenever
I can right so if I'm sitting at home
and it's like an afternoon and there was
really no reason for me not to live
stream I would live stream okay so you
should be able to expect more live
streams of course my livestream pages
twitch.tv pool / the churn oh so you
guys can follow me there and of course
on Twitter as well twitter com for such
de jure know because I usually announce
when I go live there anyway those are
those kind of two things okay now for
the other view now for the other side of
you who are more interested in game
programming in Java and that kind of
stuff this sterilization series of
course is still continuing expect
probably two episodes over the next week
to come out for that once that finishes
I'm going to be integrating that of
course into game programming and then
we'll be starting multiplayer and
whatnot so game programming is kind of
going to die down okay I'm not going to
work on it as much it's going to be more
of like a hobby kind of project rather
than the actual primary purpose of this
channel and what not again which I am
shifting more to Sparky just because I
feel like Sparky is a more viable kind
of thing right it's something that I
don't find too much of like how many how
many how many like quality 3d engine
from scratch kind of development stuff
is their unusually right now like not
much right there are a few but they kind
of stopped once they go up to the hard
parts but of course the hard parts don't
really stop me because I actually work
in the industry so I know exactly how
everything works and if I even don't
know something because it's like super
advanced I can always find out right so
I feel that that's obviously another car
another kind of selling point as to why
that kind of content might be more
useful to you guys because you just
can't currently find any you can't
really find it anywhere else anyway
again for going what I'm going to
probably try and put out like once we
get past the civilization stuff which
again will be 1 to 2 videos a week I'll
probably comfortably be able to put out
at least one video a week for game
programming so that's probably going to
happen right unless I take some kind of
holiday of course and I'm away and
whatnot that might disrupt that content
but otherwise it should be pretty good
ok the other thing I want to do this
year is do more of what I did last year
with stuff like flappy bird right where
I kind of did the entire project the
entire game in one in
kind of sitting right and again once
Sparky gets up to the point where I can
use that for that then I probably will
okay so um yeah making games an entire
sitting or at least maybe even longer
term projects like maybe again it'll
take me a week to make but then
summarizing it into one video and kind
of showing you guys how I did everything
will again be something that I'm kind of
looking forward to doing because
completing projects is always good and I
feel that showing you guys the entire
overview as well as some it's good
because this channel has always been
about showing you guys how to make
something from start to finish and we
kind of have trouble reaching the finish
section of that but um hopefully that'll
change this year on what not the other
stuff that I really want to get into is
we have been doing standalone videos in
the form of like you know event systems
and like this realization series and why
not and by standalone I just mean not
part of a series right so I want to do
more of that I want to do tutorials and
whatnot on stuff like 3d graphics
because I always get asked a lot about
that and people people people seem to
find it difficult which of course it is
but I I don't see enough content on that
are on YouTube there's actually you know
quality and that will actually be a
proper way of doing things not like a
let's do it this way for now and then
we'll change it later and then that
never comes so like quality 3d graphics
tutorials and what not that kind of
stuff I really want to get more of out
on this channel as well this year and
the thing is like graphics programming
is hands-down my favorite like part of
programming I love everything to do with
graphics because it's just so cool to me
how like we basically come up with this
series of mathematical equations which
simulate like essentially how light
works in the real world to deliver all
of these graphics to us it and not only
that because that's actually not too
difficult to do that's that's like kind
of step 1 but the thing is since we're
in the games industry and since we're
working with games they are real time
applications so not only do we have to
figure out how to do something like that
because it's not to eat it's not too
hard you know if you've got if you've
got time to offline render it you can
just retrace yourself to freaking
oblivion that's fine
but the issue is where in real-time
graphics so this stuff has to be done
under certain budget right it has to be
the entire the entire frame has to be
rendered like in like a few milliseconds
essentially so that obviously introduces
the whole performance aspect and
optimization and like approximations for
all these mathematical kind of equations
than 10 which just to me is awesome as
well so I really love talking about that
stuff and I think I'll put out more over
that if you guys are interested in that
of course so drop a comment below
basically just letting me know what you
think of everything I've described in
this video I think that's pretty much
all I've covered the other thing I
wanted to cover as well as it in at the
end of january i will be participating
in the global Game Jam I've never done
it before but a friend of mine actually
convinced me to do it so the global Game
Jam for does if you don't know it's
basically like a game jam that happens
all around the world it's actually
something it's not something you do
online kind of like a lot of their right
it's actually something that you go to a
location to do right and there are
locations all around the world you guys
can um I'll drop a link in the
description as well but you guys can can
check what locations exist in your kind
of region and yeah it's like a weekend
kind of thing as from January 29 to 31
and you essentially just make a game
it's usually done in a team so i'll be
working a team as well probably why
probably like two or three like the
teams are usually about three people i
think so um we'll see what we can do
there but the one that's in Melbourne
which is where I'll be right it's
actually happening at the University
that I that I want to write that's when
burn and it's also sponsored the
platinum sponsor is EA by Marquis which
is where I work out so it's like you
know it's basically a good place to be
and whilst I won't be doing it on behalf
of fire monkeys or anything just because
I kind of just want to make my own game
and whatnot ah not now that I think we
will be like pry my keys will be
participating it in it from what I know
but um I won't be on their team or
anything I'm just doing a cow with a
bunch of friends mine I will be there
and whatnot so if any of you guys are
going to be at the novel one then you'll
definitely see me there I've already
bought tickets and whatnot but it's a
really cool kind of jam because it kind
of all happens in a single venue and you
like people even sleep over at the venue
and it's all fully catered and
everything it's to be a lot of fun I've
ever done it before but I'm really
looking forward to it and should be
pretty awesome and you can see there's a
bunch of pretty cool sponsors as well
there but anyway i'll be doing that and
i'll probably put up some videos
regarding that and whatnot and hopefully
i'll make a pretty cool game there with
my team but it should be pretty good so
anyway that is going to be the basic
outline for what's going to happen this
year of course everything is subject to
change but if you guys agree with this
you guys are excited about this leave a
comment below hashtag hype let's get
this going and hopefully 2016 is going
to be the best year yet so I'll see you
guys later goodbye